en corvée de rénovation au camp papillon
qui relance ses activités après un arrêt
forcé par l'aco vide l'an passé la
passait c'était totalement déchiré
c'était vraiment difficile cette année
on repart les activités donc on est
vraiment plus dans l'espoir en ce samedi
75 professionnels de la construction
retable qu'un bénévolement donc mais en
guinée sous traitants top ni les
personnels l'icm en taupe des gratuits
on fait tout seul maudit comme on dit en
face à ce bras ils le font pour eux ces
enfants et ces familles pour qui le camp
papillon et le rayon de soleil de
l'année
est-ce que tout était ennuyé l'an
dernier de pavant le camp papillon
camille fréquentent le camp depuis 14
ans le seul lieu où elle se sent
entièrement acceptée telle qu'elle est
c'est un peu vraiment pour nous qui
pourrait à sa normalité et camille est
invité à jouer chez des amis le pot
vraiment d'amis ar mais ici on retrouve
ça gagne de chaume théâtraux ses amis
qui lui ressemble qui ont hâte de la
voir sa mère est soulagé d'avoir obtenu
une place c'est qu'avec les consignes de
la santé publique
impossible d'occuper les dortoirs à 100
% le nombre de campeurs doit diminuer
c'est vrai qu'on dit à 20 femmes et
bienvenue et eon rae ouvre le camp
papillon
c'est aussi vrai qu'on doit dire on est
désolé à 80 autres familles donc c'est
certain que c'est pas que les empires on
est conscient du besoin les autres quand
québécois qui accueille des enfants avec
des besoins particuliers doivent aussi
réduire le nombre de jeunes très content
de revenir paraît ni lucas nathan et ses
parents sont soulagés par la réouverture
une semaine de répit ou est-ce que c'est
maintenant on peut faire autre chose ça
leur fait beaucoup de bien ça leur
paraît cher au projet est pour moi aussi
bahia mais lui aussi va apprécier cette
petite pause de ses parents entre autres
pour faire du ski nautique
meilleur mois de l'année combler mais
amy rose apprécie bien sûr tyrolienne et
elle aussi le fait d'être plus autonomes
pendant une semaine on verra conduire
après on s'en va est bien contents de
nous voir partis et toutes les familles
souhaitent revenir en 2022 alors que les
cas on devrait finalement fonctionner à
100% ici david gêne-t-il et radio canada
mon frère